[Music]
in transferring identities news
submitted by Caesar my favorite salad
that's a good salad it's not anchovies
what an influencer is being accused of
the strangest scam to stay in the
spotlight who are we talking about I
need to learn these techniques Nick
avocados avocados I can't believe his
name is Nico Cano avocado dude I heard
of this guy like four years ago when
like he stopped being vegan and like he
was getting a type of Higginson healed
like 10,000 followers it was like and I
was like all this guy's name is Nick
econo avocado every time his name gets
said he should get smacked in the face
that name is obnoxious well let me tell
you about something even more obnoxious
yes what about Johnny Appleseed this guy
right Rumble with Johnny Appleseed I
want to hear about this guy thank you so
this guy his name it is paul Zimmer
anyone hurt no because we're all adults
reasonable name reasonable there's work
for like the kids on the tic TOCs and
the new tic TOCs yeah so he had seven
million followers on musically on a tic
toc musical we I don't know anyway so
yeah but then once tick tock bought
musically then his followers got
transferred over to tick tock and so he
was pretty big in like I think he
started in 2015 but then by 2017 that's
when he had this like whole scandal
where people were canceling him or
whatever because what was happening was
he was going on music Lee's sister app
lively which is where a live stream one
yeah the live stream one and so like you
so fans would pay for stickers and this
is like actual money you know yeah
badges yeah badges so then he would be
saying like oh if you give me this
sticker I'll do this for you or whatever
and so fans would like a cam girl yeah
that's essentially what it is it's like
send them
or whatever it is and then so he would
promise these things and not follow
through so then a lot of people were
like what the [ __ ] that's the worst kind
of can girl exactly yeah that's a wife
we're doing boot boomer humor all day
everybody all day guys where's your
drums at did it silent it was a good
joke it's like it's loading that's the
sound of a boomer telling a joke so this
was back in 2017 and then he just
disappeared off of social media good but
then he ends up coming back to social
media and he posts something that says
so it's this one photo and I'll show you
in a second he says this actor at Troy
Becker kid literally looks like a
younger sexier version of me laughing
emoji I don't even use social media
anymore but I had to post this ha ha ha
more social up emojis but here we go
this is Paul Zimmer well they do look
alike Troy Bakley it's him oh I'm stupid
[ __ ] TIFF gave it away
well did I [ __ ] stupid cuz I didn't
see here you've been dumber than we
thought wait you're watching a movie
where we all the spoilers were in the
trailer and you're like wha Freaky
Friday these switch bodies just like
this is Paul Paul would be happy that
you responded all I'd love to meet you
Paul's hanging out with you do the
bathroom real quick he can hail my
friend Jimmy he comes out of the
bathroom and Jude Jill's like Jimmy's
really cool I like him I know my horse I
wish Paul would be here like Lois Lane
though
that's just Clark whatever Clark I can't
talk to you more Clark up in love with
Superman Superman Clark Superman Clark
wait where did Joe go yeah there is oh
wait just like Joe when he shaved his
face then I'm with two year old that's
when Paul started posting certain things
and then he was just like man you know
what he's just crazy like I'm telling
you this is my literal twin brother it's
so he said in all caps I'm telling you
he's my younger brother and then crying
laughing emoji and then he ends up
saying something like why is he giving
it away he's giving it away there - no
he's like he's my younger twin much
younger twin I believed much young 15 or
16 years old
hahahaha I'm gonna go younger instead of
older like it's so much easier to go
older yeah that guy doesn't like baby
fees is he trying to like have the girls
fall in love with the younger trend but
he's so bad in this okay so I have a
friend who was telling me that she was
wall playing with her husband and they
were role-playing that they're strangers
who just met and apparently so they
start making out and stuff and then he's
on saying oh I just met you and just met
you oh right he's so bad at it that's
what this cut I can't believe I just met
you he said it like we're not
role-playing anymore just shut the [ __ ]
out he said three times a minute and
she's like what the [ __ ] nobody talks
like that
my abort story dude exactly so I'm gonna
show you guys a video clip and the first
few tic TOCs is Paul Zimmer okay and
then after you're gonna see I'm sure he
announces it it's gonna be Troy he
buddy's gotta blow my mind what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how many virgins what are we gonna do
watch this forever [ __ ] like what else
do we watching it's rubber
yeah my name is Troy Becker I'm an after
positive are reached out to me and asked
to record a video because he says he
really really looks like me
and he wanted to post it on any social
media everything it's called not
American buttons are an American accent
on his account so nice to meet you guys
he says I'm an American actor videos
yeah so I am an American y'all it's like
he's gone hello Isis captured me I am an
American does he have a British accent
originally and used to stuff that I'm
wondering like it's nothing just got so
weird
well he's doing that to kind of like so
people will watch and go is that him or
not yeah oh and a scandal he got
cancelled yeah so I'm just trying to
come back as a different person so yeah
he still gets the money in the following
but it's not him any I can't change his
hair or something I know its color do
something
Laurie was like this one beeping yeah
and then now he's just dyed it dark and
then so another looks the same season I
mean I missed how bad his scandal was I
wouldn't say is that crazy bad for you
to disappear off of social media for two
years and they come back as a different
person bad was it
it was the fact that he wasn't following
through he was a bad camera oh yeah I
forgot about that yes that's why he got
canceled yeah I know so many people
though that don't follow through on [ __ ]
like cuz you're not like someone paid
for goods and services and then you
didn't know just that but like these
these users are like 13 year olds too so
it just like makes it even more creepy
that's not like getting cancelled
because you said you didn't get your
post - but you got it do we did that by
accident we did that by accident and
every funder doesn't I felt some time
like to make you look bad we didn't know
yeah we thought they were missing part
of the order but it was like really hit
all we've done that yeah I was [ __ ]
pissed
to give the next kind of big tip okay
while the other guy gets fired that
people have pointed out is that after
like a few months before you even like
four months before he came out with his
first post about Troy he was stealing
and in these acting classes with with
Paul Zimmer's fiance Becca was seen well
Zimmer's fiance had an acting class
she's a ho he needs to get better acting
lessons yeah Gio calls it out she's like
hey weren't you just with that other guy
like wait a minute yes listen I don't
think that cheating stuff is right okay
wasn't you the gal that was with that
other guy with the string we got some
people aren't commenting on a stick talk
they're saying like Paul it's really
creepy you're pretending to be 16 he's
falling for it you're literally wearing
the same post photos in your voices are
the same no calling that calling a 16
year old version of yourself younger and
sexier
that is bizarre is it is it bad to say
that sometimes I wish bullying was okay
no I wish someone bullying I think he's
getting bullied yeah okay he's not
getting away with it well I think people
should bully him so he doesn't have any
of these stupid ideas we learn all of
his audience that used to follow him
back then are now in a different level
of teenager like they were 13 now
they're like 17 or whatever so they're
like very clearly like not fooled by it
whereas before you might have gotten
away with it because they were like very
young yeah exactly so then yeah people
are just like what the [ __ ] are you
doing man but he's still posting tic
TOCs regularly so I don't know it's
almost fun to watch as a different type
of fan like Wendy if you like following
people that that make their lives fall
apart on camera like a spectator of that
it's a more fun he's gonna introduce a
new demographic I love that it's a
g-rated version you should have just
came back as himself like is it cool
looking like a good-looking boy you know
I could see a lot of like teenager or
like teeny bumpkins mental is not quite
there yeah but all he's doing is just
lip-syncing right right so it takes a
lot of skill have you guys seen that uh
Netflix like documentary series the
don't [ __ ] with cats no oh you should
watch it it's okay I thought it was
about cats I skipped it no no so the
whole thing what it is what's about it's
about this [ __ ] psycho named Luka
Magnotta who was he was posting videos
online of torturing kittens oh no no
it's really bad but like the way that
the internet like figured out who he was
and like oh he got beat up no no the
internet found him in destroy his life
know what ended up happening was it gets
really really crazy but he ends up like
just doing like getting attentions for
the kittens wasn't enough for him so he
actually went a step further and
actually killed a human being and so
like he was like on an international
like manhunt it was crazy
but the reason why bring him up is
because Luka Magnotta was so obsessed
with himself that he created a [ __ ] ton
of fan accounts for himself it was like
an insane account insane amount I forgot
have any but but like he was just so and
he was a really good looking guy like he
was trying to be a model and stuff oh my
gosh he was just not all there like he
was so vain and I keep so narcissistic
that he
all this attention and that's why he was
doing these like these kitten videos and
kind of like throwing in like self
compliments lose because he wanted to
get caught like he it was like a serial
killer thrill and like the cat-and-mouse
game I mean some people they need to get
bullied to prevent them from doing dumb
[ __ ] further down dumb [ __ ] down the
line yeah it's crime prevention pushes
them to do it you learn that [ __ ]
with cats is [ __ ] up from somebody
who's like hey [ __ ] you for [ __ ] with
cats yeah then that's tight that's what
I hear I hear you yeah so I see the
similarities in the way where Paul
Zimmer still has to be in front of the
camera he's still needed the attention
he's gets left in the face once he's
gonna do whatever he can to have a boy
way he wants to be an actor too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]